all right dez bryant been out of the nfl
for a while now remember he was with the
saints in 2018 for like one practice and
ruptured achilles tendon
out for all of 2019 and now chris
working out with the baltimore ravens
i think the workout will be later this
week not today but he's got to
pass a couple of cobit 19 tests before
he's allowed to work out even though
teams can bring players in
it's not as simple it's not as clean as
it used to be where you just fly in a
bunch of guys you work them out and you
send them home
they have to pass those tests in advance
you gotta presumably put them up at a
hotel while they wait for
their clearance to actually show up and
work out but as we place some fill in
the blanks
on this tuesday edition of pft live dez
bryant's tryout with the
ravens will be what chris well
will be interesting i think is all i'm
gonna say there for right now
i mean there's a lot to you know where
is dez bryant
at physically i mean that's not an easy
injury to come overcome like you talked
about you know tearing your achilles
tendon
and then yeah it's been a long time
since he played football
so i think he can you know impress
in the workout and do things like that i
will say this
if he is anywhere near where he was
before this injury or anything like that
i do think baltimore is a great fit for
dez bryant i mean to me that would be
one of those where i'd look at and go
wait here's a guy that's just starving
to play football and be on a team
right he just wants to be a part of it
he's a guy that
you know maybe they don't have on their
roster right now
a proven commodity can catch the ball
over the middle
be tough that way i mean that's where
dez bryant made his money that way
and then he'll block in the running game
and do that you know he fits the mantra
of the ravens so
it's all going to be just about where
he's at physically
uh and what he's got left in the tank i
think if he has a legitimate chance of
you know getting to getting a chance to
make the team
well i'll tell you from my perspective i
look at it and i say this workout is
going to be delicate because
where's antonio brown you've got lamar
jackson
hollywood brown who have been pushing
and pushing and pushing for antonio
brown i almost wonder whether or not dez
bryant is kind of like the compromise
candidate like like
let's change the subject really we're
really don't we really not comfortable
bringing antonio brown we're gonna have
to wait for him for eight games there's
unresolved issues with the
sexual assault and rape lawsuit in
florida so he could still be suspended
again
how about this how about this lamar
we'll bring in dez bryant and we'll give
him a workout and we'll see how it goes
and maybe we'll sign him
and maybe dez bryant is benefiting from
the fact that there's so much
pressure coming from within the team to
pursue antonio brown and the team
i think doesn't want to pursue antonio
brown dez bryant is the
offering to kind of get this pressure
off of them to continue to pursue
antonio brown yeah yeah i mean maybe
you're right well they're they're
obviously in need of a number two
receiver they obviously don't feel
comfortable about who they got as number
two
or the fact that it's not a proven
commodity maybe they don't look at willy
snead as that two guy
you know and you know duvernay who's a
third round pick out of texas maybe
they're just not ready to hand him the
keys to the car to be the number two guy
yet either
you know just with the the antonio brown
conversation now dez bryant being
involved in it too this is receivers
veteran receivers linked to the wide you
know wide receiver position in baltimore
they obviously have a need or something
that they don't like about that group
altogether
all right when it comes to calling plays
brown's coach kevin stefanski
should what chris and this question
comes specifically from the fact that
alex van pelt the offensive coordinator
called the plays on offense for the
first two days of practice what should
stefanski do
all the plays are not called when it
comes to calling plays kevin stefanski
should call the plays that's what he
should do
yes i mean that's part of the reason
he's there as the head coach of the
cleveland browns
is because yes his offensive coordinator
calling plays i know gary kubiak got
involved in minnesota too and all those
type of things
you know and i the offensive coordinator
right there now alex van pelt
hey i like him certainly there's a lot
to respect
i guess what i just worry about is hey
this is your first year as a head coach
kevin
kevin stefanski alex van per ben peltz
never
really been in your system per se and
you know hasn't seen in which the way
you want to
you know devise a game plan and then you
know how do you want to orchestrate your
play calling and sequence it all
together and do those things so
i would say at the very least if i'm
kevin stevenski i would start the season
off
calling plays nonetheless to kind of
show that offensive coordinator hey this
is the way i'd like to do it
and play the game through our team and
everything like that
this is the ultimate test for a coach
who got his job by being an offensive
coordinator because that's what got you
the job exactly calling the plays
designing the offense got you the job
but the problem is some guys can't do
the
macro of running the team on game day
and the micro
of calling the plays jason garrett comes
to mind and he eventually
surrendered calling the plays in dallas
because he couldn't do both
so that's the challenge so i say this i
got no problem with stefanski doing it
as long as he can do it he needs to be
self-aware and he needs to be willing to
self-scout thyself
if he can't do it yeah and delegate it
after a season
after a season or two if he can't do it
he needs to step aside from it all right
quickly on the way out chris we had a
couple of defensive injuries yesterday
robert offered the new defensive back in
arizona trey waynes who went from
minnesota to cincinnati
they both are out with injuries this a
big deal medium deal or no impact for
those two teams
big deal i mean the arizona cardinals
their past defense stunk last year
it's stunk they have a cornerback issue
there
you know we know patrick peterson's
there he wasn't as good last year
so you know robert alford was supposed
to help that out that's a big deal and
so was train wait
trey wayne's with the cincinnati bangles
i mean they paid him a lot of money they
paid him like he's one of the top five
six corners in football
so that's an expensive loss for them
there you know opposite of william
jackson it's gonna hurt both their teams
yeah look wayne's uh was a
disappointment in minnesota still
anytime you need help defensively you
need depth you need healthy corners
and you went outside those guys for a
reason and if you don't have them
available that
was around you surprised how much money
they paid trey wins there in cincinnati
and no i'm not surprised because the
guys who get the market are the guys who
get paid
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports